Good morning Daniel!
Dan, please...
I’m Marcia Boardman – we spoke on the
phone – and this is Philip Hart, our CEO.
Hello!
Nice to meet you both.
So it says here on your CV that you’re interested
in rock climbing...
Yeah... love it!
Great – so do I!
When did you last go climbing?
Oh, err, well, it was a while ago now...
Anywhere interesting?
Yeah.
I walked up the hill behind my house.
Took me about thirty minutes!
Oh.
OK, erm, Daniel, can you tell us a little
bit about your current position?
Certainly – as it says in the CV, I’m
part of the European Sales team at Networld.
We’re the world’s leading supplier of
IT hardware.
Why do you want to move on?
Well, they’re too small for me.
Networld!?
Networld are too small for you?
Oh yeah.
I’m looking for something much bigger.
Well, we’re not a big company by any means,
but we are looking to grow!
What first attracted you to WebWare in particular?
Well, I see WebWare as kind of like a stepping
stone...
Sorry?
Yeah, start here gain the necessary experience,
then move onto something bigger.
OK... well, I do admire your ambition!
Thanks – I’ve got lots of it!
Let’s move on to managing people.
Can you give an example of a time when you
had to deal with a particularly difficult
managee?
Sure – well I think that’s one of my strong
points actually.
A couple of years ago, I was working with
a guy, he wasn’t pulling his weight, basically
being lazy – so I told him to get out.
Oh, you didn’t give him a performance review,
or a warning, or perhaps try to help develop
his motivation?
No, no, no.
None of that rubbish.
If someone’s not working hard enough, then
they’re out!
That’s the way I work.
I’m a hard man.
I see.
How would you handle a rapidly changing market?
Basically not change anything at all!
Just continue on as normal regardless!
According to your CV you are fluent in Mandarin...
Well, I wouldn’t say ‘fluent’ exactly...
but, I like Chinese food a lot – so I can
read the menu!
So you can’t actually speak the language?
Erm, no.
Can you tell us about a time you had to close
a particularly challenging deal.
I haven’t had one.
They’re all easy for me.
I close deals all the time!
OK – well do you have any questions for
us?
No.
Oh.
OK.
Erm.
Thanks.
Let’s move on to the presentation...